we do have a story that just broke on
Bloomberg News just before we came on
here it's exclusively quite a story
we've heard about mine shkreli a fair
amount because you've been checking up
the price of this rumor suta khals and
also buying millions for the pay
millions for that our show has been
waiting for we be I'm gonna fall down
but this is a very different story a
really important story about mr. shkreli
and for that we're gonna carry Geyer who
did break the story Carrie I could
morning David so very interesting
exciting news in the world of
pharmaceuticals and of course Martin
shkreli who's been dubbed by the media
as the you know the bad boy of the
Pharma Center see he was arrested today
on suspicion of securities fraud and
it's not related to what he's really
been criticized for over the last
several weeks which is hiking up the
price of life-saving drugs through his
his company turing pharmaceuticals but
it's actually transactions and payments
that he made using money from a previous
firm that he founded called retrofits so
he basically is accused of taking money
and stock from a trophy and using it to
pay off personal and biz on related
personal and business debts carrie would
he ever have been caught or even looked
at had he not been in the news dubbed
the bad boy well I think that's an
interesting question I think that
obviously this case would not be such a
big deal if he hasn't it didn't have
such a huge public profile but
interestingly enough the company which
she's accused of taking money for which
he founded in 2011 retro Fionn actually
sued him in August for many of these
same issues that federal prosecutors are
now looking at him for so it was been
laid out in a civil lawsuit and federal
prosecutors basically took a really
close look at those allegations and they
might have even started looking before
that and this is just straight-up
securities fraud basically taking money
from one pot to pay off people that he
owed money to
and according to both the lawsuit and
how these charges are gonna roll out he
did not have the company's permission to
do that Carrie this is quite a story our
own care
Geiger braking this I'm not you know
what he's a punk
not necessarily the bad boy at a hedge
fund energy at this point I think it's
kind of safe to say the punk